[Music]
growth brings wisdom our intellectual
emotional moral and spiritual
foundations determine what we can
receive boom what's up everyone welcome
to simulation I'm your host Don sake and
super excited to be talking about
ancient wisdom in modern times we have
Niles Heckman joining us on the show
hello pleasure to be with you sir thank
you so much for coming on yeah really
excited for this episode now is
background he's a documentarian whose
personal work focuses on themes of
ancient wisdom and the links in the bio
to Niles hackman.com as well as
transmutation film calm in shamans of
the global village calm which we will be
unpacking here that was a short excerpt
from transmutation film I'm excited to
be talking about that and documentarian
work in general let's start things off
with one of our favorite questions to
ask our guest Niles what are your
thoughts in the direction of our world I
think a lot of this species seems to be
de-evolving and then a smaller
percentage seems to be in a brilliant
point of evolution and that seems like
what 2012 is about right like the
argument of larger metaphysical things
going on from Pisces to Aquarius of like
the species finally waking up to some
extent and you have you could argue
there's the hundredth monkey scenario
which some people talk about where a
smaller more sophisticated and
enlightened group of people understand
more under rooted things about what's
secretly really going on and a larger
mass is asleep still so I know as you
have a show called simulation much of
that maybe focuses around themes a theme
that's similar to some what some of my
work focuses on which is a Gnostic
mindset of like this reality being
illusory and how much people really
realize that what's really going on is
different than what is proposed by the
mainstream reality tunnel or what I
would say is they mean the Joker spirals
of the mainstream unreality signal right
so that's kind of a dynamic where you
see a lot of people that are what's
called being on a latent path you know
just going sideways or on a descendent
path if they're in some sort of personal
destruction doing you know
methamphetamine in the Civic's
over here like you know incarcerated or
selling you know some sort of narcotic
on the street doing a life of crime
that's descended there's most people are
on a latent path they're just kind of
going sideways even if they have you
know a Stanford degree in three PhDs
they might just be doing their job in
their routine and doing kids and work
kids and work and they're just lately
doing things but then a smaller
percentage of people are doing more
excellent things on an ascended path
where they're trying to be in a constant
point of betterment and discovery so I
think as we kind of start in that
processor the whole species slowly moves
in that process or at least a smaller
percentage of people do we can see that
we find the others that are doing
excellent things as well and you know we
all can only do our little part but as
long as you're trying to always be in
some level of betterment or discovery
and get my vote for sure and then what
would you say are some of the key things
that those that are on the this
ascendant path of self work and
discovery and transcendence and helping
the collective as well doing focus on
that what can they best do to help
awaken others to that realization of
just and you use the word Gnosticism
yeah the Gnostic spiritual you know
teach us about that yeah yeah well I
mean I'm a documentary filmmaker at
least I feel like I'm half amateur half
professional what I do but you could put
this word to the forefront that my work
focuses around themes of spirituality
most people that's such a loaded term
and like sturgeons law says 90% of
everything is crap so just like with
spirituality there's a lot of bad
spirituality out there so I don't
necessarily put spirituality at the
forefront I would say that my work
combines essentially a cult and esoteric
content with high production value
most people don't also know what a cult
or esoteric mean so an even more down in
the weeds way of saying what I do is my
work focuses on themes of mysticism
alchemy hermetic philosophy shamanism or
maybe something like Gnosticism right
these are ancient spiritual philosophic
practices most people don't know what
those are so another zoom out from that
is I could just say that my work focuses
on themes of ancient wisdom or ancient
knowledge combined with my background of
having
high production values you know so it's
like you create something that looks
good
has the professionalism behind it and
then you actually have an underlying
thing to say and so something when you
insert something like Gnosticism it is
something even famous works like The
Matrix and I worked on the matrix equals
as a young sprout you know people don't
know about that they don't understand it
but they can still heart string feel
into it feel that there's some sort of
underlying things that speaks to their
what you could argue is their
subconscious or their deeper self so
when you insert wisdom into things or
any of these ancient practices that have
huge power in them I think there's a lot
of reward in that for sure so that's
what I kind of always try and do an ever
so slight lays with my life and my work
and how I intrinsically em and what
exteriorly manifests in my works right
like how we internally leave it live our
life our spiritual life which if you
want to put spiritual to the forefront a
good way that I always try and say it is
that spiritual just essentially means
truthful right it's just how you
truthfully live your life and how you
try and be on some sort of ascendant way
of being or betterment or else expansion
right like everything you try and do you
try and be expansive in so you try and
you know are conscious about everything
that you do you're conscious about how
what you put in your body how you live
your life who you associate with who
your interact with you're not doing
contractive things you're not you know
watching the sporting event at the pub
even though we all might do that here
and there but there's all the traps of
the illusions of the mainstream
unreality of Joker spiral signal always
wants you to do contractive things and I
try and insert something ever so
slightly that does expand that provides
media that is expansive just like you
might be trying to do with the show
right where you're trying to have more
conscious conversations and you created
a platform where people can talk about
real [ __ ] that's right yeah so you're so
your essence with the documentary work
is to disseminate high-quality
productions of ancient wisdom that can
awaken and inspire people yeah or like
the way to say it is that for those with
ears to hear because you can't wake
anybody up that doesn't want to be woken
up that's a classic Gnostic theme with
those willing to hear with yeahit's eyes
to see and ears to hear is one
way of looking at it and I'm not any I
don't present myself as a scholar or
anything I'm just a student of life and
student of these ancient practices right
and so it's like the big failure of like
the Guru or there's somebody that's
allowing themselves to be elevated is to
say like I'm claiming more than I really
am so when you're just saying I'm
learning and I'm on a path of betterment
I'm not trying to preach anything but
yeah when you start talking about
something like esotericism which is such
a personal path and is such a path of
inner understanding and your own gnosis
and your own wisdom through whatever way
that came it is very contagious because
you can present yourself of a way of
being and living and acting in the world
that reflects on to other people and
they just read that they read your
geometry in you as doing something
excellent right you don't have to stand
on some soapbox and preach things that
are very dogmatic and old-fashioned ways
yeah and that's that's what I'm always
doing is as my life has changed and
bettered and I've understood deeper
things that have brought me gnosis or
insight or experience the works also
reflect that so it's like my life
hopefully reflects that ever so slightly
and the works do as well and that's why
you know I see a lot of content online
these days a lot of it's visually
beautiful but it has a little to nothing
to say it's all this base chakra stuff
so when you can kind of try and make
something that's a higher vibrational
energy which we could sound a little
woowoo but ultimately everything is
energetic when you start putting out
that signal you know people respond to
it a bit even though you're sometimes it
feels like you're speaking to smaller
again groups of more sophisticated and
enlightened people there's channels now
that allow us to bypass these
gatekeepers and get more authentic stuff
to the forefront so you've created
something yourself here with the show
that is also we have a similarity of
what we're doing trying to just do our
own thing and be our authentic selves
follow our own ways of being and acting
that reflect in our outward
manifestations yes yeah thank you and
who were you growing up that got you
interested in documentary work yeah you
know it was interesting I was always a
kid that liked liked cinema in my past
in my more stupid past when I didn't
know anything growing up I a lot of
everything was a reflection on a movie
like the movies teach us things later in
life as I came to work at Hollywood and
realized it was a place that had some
decent things about it but like
sturgeons law everything of 90% of
everything is crap so 90% of what goes
on
is very you know naughty not in your
best interests like just like anything
from standard operating procedure of
capitalism or Wall Street there's deep
levels of dark sorcery that are so very
soul sucking in these places and people
get into these systems of you know
shadow workings within the music
industry and realize that they
essentially have to do these dark things
to sustain some level of fame and
fortune or red carpet champagne dreams
and there's it's beautiful to have a
reach and have people like your material
and know your stuff and I'm certainly as
any artist I'm no different than the
standard artist that wants to have their
work be known so it's nice to to share
what you're doing but you ultimately
come to realize that these things aren't
your best interest and you might be able
to somewhat balance working in them
right but I came to realize that any
client work I ever did was significantly
less interesting than the work I would
create myself because I was essentially
too conscious for that industry right
it's like we're having a conversation
with you know rod about this about you
know you get to the point where you
can't really operate in the old way of
being you know so as I was growing up I
got into Hollywood and I saw what it did
well and what it did not well and I have
a lot of respect for certain people
within the industry and I know people
within the industry that are trying to
do decent things but then getting
content that's any anything expansive
past these gatekeepers is very difficult
right so every once in a while you will
see a gem right you will see something
like the matrix you know that has some
sort of actual wisdom in her eye I
worked on avatar and my more stupid pass
what I didn't know anything and made a
lot of money and now as I know things
you know there's new streams of revenue
beginning and creating my own content
but something like avatar has very
shamanic themes and people don't know
that but they resonate so we do see
things coming out of large big budget
projects that at times are pretty good
so I give credit when I and occasionally
watching something that is like oh this
is great I'm really happy that this was
made and it's not a piece of dark
sorcery that's just there to be an OP or
some sort of something that's giving a
misrepresentation of what it is to
actually be a real human being and be on
a path of betterment in Discovery it's
just distraction and illusion and we see
that so much with entertainment
industries yeah you think we're gonna
get to the distraction illusion side
thanks - I want to were you ever when
you were younger were you ever just the
first moments with cameras just got
really excited about it or whether for
moments with spiritual growth yourself
got really excited know I became much
more I guess as I reference 2012 2012 is
a big year where things kind of clicked
for me you know so I would say I was
well into my 20s in my more again stupid
past not knowing anything where before I
really kind of started to understand
things and I had had an interest in kind
of more off-the-beaten-path things right
I liked Garbage Pail Kids more than
something more mainstream right so
esotericism is such an inner thing and
it's about those that are kind of
Outsiders and rejects so as somebody the
young kid rebels against the mainstream
Leave It to Beaver
you know materialist rubbish culture of
white picket fence suburban hellish
America you know you're into punk music
or something like that or you're into
skater culture you're into these aspects
that are rebellious nature's and the
unstruck you know Joker spirals of
unreality and just delusion and
distraction that don't benefit us as
conscious conscious excellent beings so
I think we do have these avenues that we
go down that are different and I did
find my path and you know occasionally
reading excellent things that were had
actual wisdom in them or seeing
something that was a more
off-the-beaten-path piece of graphic
novel you know I loved Alan Moore's
graphic novels that type of thing where
there's actually like occult themes and
these things so there was pieces of art
that really did inspire and then as I
got into my 20s I really started to
things clicked and I really started to
become on more of a path of excellence
through various experiences and
spiritual practices right and through
having a meditative practice so various
experiences that you know would give us
some sort of gnosis or logos and that's
just fractal doubt from there and the
projects that are I've created into my
30s what would be a recommendation that
you would have for those that are how
developing the eyes and the ears to to
see that there's more to life than the
Joker spirals yeah like where can they
find signal how can they parse for the
signal it's very it's an important
question because it's so hard to find
real content and a lot of excellent
stuff isn't even on the internet and as
we know like big any eye sometimes and I
often in conversations use this phrase
we're like big anything lowers human
consciousness right so to piss everybody
off I say like big corporations big
government big science big religion
obviously if you're operating within
these things
more like grassroots level you're
probably going to go after truth you
know if you're okay if you're operating
in some way where you're like an actual
real excellent you know you have a
little Church in a small community and
you're actually saying things that are
more Gnostic themes of actual real
esoteric Christianity you might be
searching out excellence or if you're
operating if you're a small business
owner you know you might be doing things
that are it's nice to support the local
community but as things get so big
there's no wisdom in them they're just
about the dollar signs and maintaining
the status quo so it's hard to go into
big tech and find wisdom on areas of you
know Facebook or these delusions of
Twitter and YouTube but we do find
things that are excellent and big tech
is very much purging things that aren't
necessarily expansive so one way that I
would say is study the specific life
work of people you know seek out
people's works who are excellent you
know and usually you find somebody's
works that really fractal you out and
make you realize bigger things and then
that bounces you off to somebody else
right so you find Robin in town Wilson's
material you read a book by Robert Anton
Wilson and they are talking about
Terence Mckenna and they lead you to
somebody like Alan Watts yes so you find
these specific individuals who actually
started to know things and and talk
about things and they reference other
people and then that's very much how in
terms of my just studies I always do it
and I have a list of people that are
actually like I call them the people
that new things list of people and
they're it's always growing and it's
always improving because I'm always
myself finding new people that new
things but most people in a layton path
in our society all they know how to do
is essentially be in their little sliver
of Commerce which is fine you know
commerce restricts is commerce is
another whole thing that we could talk
about but human beings are not
commercial traders so we're not meant to
just go to our sheykh jobs every day and
that's all that we do until we hit the
golf course at 60 you know there's much
more to life than that so it's great if
you like what you do and it gives you
time and space for your own practices
but ultimately that's only gonna come
from your own you know own direction and
that's certainly what I found is that as
I create works that are I learn from
creating them just like you learn from
the conversations you have on this thing
it becomes this spiral that feeds it so
water you know it's for
this conversation yeah so far your
crumpet yeah yeah and I'm I try not to
be too long-winded I could happily talk
for 14 minutes you're crushing it so I
like how you said that one of the ways
out of the Joker spirals and distraction
to find the signal is to seek out
people's life works yeah and then to
kind of do like you're starting to
follow a signal trail between people why
is it that there's the one of the people
that I admire is sitting down with this
person why is it about this person so
then you look into that person yes and
okay and that's how you can maybe start
doing out also I really appreciate out
you said like big anything is actually
restrictive really contractive
contractive like a lot of it is that I'm
the family values don't scale so like my
tendency to self deal as Google or
Facebook is just more likely than my
tendency to be like I care about Niles
Heckman and Ron Vargas yeah and so I'm
going to do things that that show that I
specifically am tailoring my algorithms
to something that's going to benefit
their health and their wellness and all
this type of stuff yeah rather than
their time on-screen types of style so
yeah that that was also a very good
point okay so let's let's launch into
the the ancient wisdom within the actual
so let's start with transmutation so we
watched the very short clip that we wash
at the beginning so teach us about this
film and what you're doing with the
ancient wisdom in it yeah I mean
transmutation is a feature doc that we
made completely independently you know
it's very rare to find a truly
independent film and so it's essentially
about the beauty and danger of a hidden
spiritual path and shows people that
have transformed themselves which has
really transmute themselves by walking
in right so alchemy a secret to alchemy
is the transmutation of one's self
esoterically ancient alchemy you could
say is a precursor to the chemistry
right and the the stereotype of alchemy
is that you know in ancient days they
were just trying to turn lead to gold
right they were being very materialistic
about it
a deeper way of looking at that again
the inner core of something will be this
esoteric or it will be the wizard behind
the curtain and it won't be broadcast in
the mainstream you have to seek it out
almost yourself and it's gonna be like
secret codes invented in the in the
circuit board right so the secret to
alchemy is the transmutation of oneself
and that's like what we're all
essentially trying to do we're trying to
change ourselves from an old self that
was the version 1.0 of Allen into a
version 2.0 3.0 and that's trying to be
always in a process of betterment and
discovery and of course it's not a race
you know we all have to live in commerce
we all have our jobs we all have to
support ourselves I understand that and
it's not anybody to judge which race on
those types of things but transmutation
just highlights people that are doing
their part ever so slightly in walking
that walk and talking the talk and
spiritual our growth in life
obviously the clip mentioned growth is
just our life growth or our spiritual
growth that's what ultimately humans are
designed to do were decide we're here to
grow in this reality in this you know
what we could call a simulation of the
realm of Earth right like we aren't you
can have a very high-level metaphysical
conversation about us being spiritual
beings having a human experience yeah
but why are we here in material 3d
reality it's like we're here to have
experiences and then at some point be
like what did you learn yeah rights okay
that is obviously a process of change
and you can't change without you know
expelling old ways of doing things and
as we expel all the ways of doing things
we may lose friendships or have
different relationships you know things
come and go but like nature does you
know we look to nature as a teacher
animistic cultures from the past they
had a connection to Great Spirit and as
we talk more about this with shamans of
level village but you know we had these
deeper connections to our higher selves
you could say our nature or wisdom or
Gaia or cosmos or Pachamama so
transportation is very much in this
flavor of this esoteric practices such
as alchemy and mysticism and hermetic
philosophy so these are ancient
spiritual philosophic systems that
project wisdom through a path that you
take and it you can read about it but
ultimately you must experience it
through the various things that you do
and as we were making the film it was a
very transformational process in making
it so I was trying I'm gonna make
something that's gonna be a very
difficult project and I'm going to get
paid much less money for it might as
well be life transformative yeah yes yes
this again so much good stuff I want to
know what are the people doing in
transmutation that are helping them grow
yeah yeah they're rejecting old ways of
being and knowing and they're there they
have built up a discernment to see what
is good information versus what is bad
information and as anybody that's on a
path of betterment or discovery you're
like if you spend your time with earbuds
in your ears listening to a great audio
book or a yummy podcast and you're just
searching out any sort of things that
are like how can I better myself through
my own personal time that's great and so
we highlight people in this film of
course which is very much it has a theme
of
a voiceover of kind of a spiritual
philosophical voiceover by my brilliant
colleague Neil Cramer who is essentially
a real mystic a real actual mystic wrote
this documentary and then we show actual
people to kind of break that up that are
doing things that are transformative in
their life through the ways of being and
acting within the world that are very
unconventional but still like all of us
you know we have a mixture of our
standard operating lives in suburbia or
in the city that we have to kind of do
our daily chores or maybe have our job
but it's all about the balance of these
things and we highlight them much in the
film like the wisdom of the Sun and Moon
for example these divine opposites that
give us an allegory of a masculine and
feminine thing yeah and the balance of
these things and how much life is so
much about the balance of things for our
own personal betterment right it's like
do you that's what that's my issue I
always how it's not that I don't like
tech or like big data or like technology
it's just how stupidly much we work
right it's like we work these Protestant
work ethics that are nuts and it's great
if you are on some leading edge of
technology working on blockchain and but
if you work in 90 hours a week you can't
work on your spiritual growth and I know
it's even worse in other countries like
Japan so it's just the balance of how
much we do things so there you go so
people that are finding balance and
finding wisdom through the way that
they're living their lives and some of
the experiences that they're having
because it's all experiencial there's
the this-this-this had there has to be
pulled up reference this is too good for
from from literally today oh do you yeah
yeah Ron will Ron will bring it up right
now oh there you go yeah yeah okay
congratulations you're hired
thank you I am so grateful for this
opportunity to wake up at 6 a.m. and sit
in traffic so that I can stare at a
computer screen for eight hours every
day yeah one thing that we highlight in
transmutation is essentially this modern
perspective on Empire
right which is always existed and Empire
is there to crush the spiritual growth
of every node on the network right so
over time eons of time you know Empire
has come to the forefront through like
ancient days and you saw it most
highlighted in like theocratic times in
the Dark Ages when everybody you know if
you said the wrong thing you'd have your
head cut off or you stepped on the Kings
shadow in ancient Hawaii and they'd stab
you you know these times where it's like
nobody could say anything and now we do
live in crazy times yeah but we can say
stuff and we if we were having this
conversation 500 years ago we'd be like
dead you know
burned to a crisp so it's beautiful
times to be a literally yeah happened to
pair the Bruno saying things
yes Giovanna Bruno yes yes for speaking
a little bit too much truth you know
nobody still to this day in this society
by saying a lot of truthful things get
you anywhere usually stand-up comedy is
a great medium because you can actually
music exactly the art the and the arts
have always tried to great art will
always try and inject something that is
a source of betterment through the art
right so I do consider myself having
come out of it the background being an
artist still very much an artist in the
works and I hope that reflects and the
production values of the content but
actually an artist that hopefully has
things to say so in that rambling I
forgot your initial question arts role
is to like embed these most sacred
aspects of like self work and spiritual
wisdom and all these types of things
like that's part of art's role because
you can embed it with music or poetry or
comedy or film ah anyway huge when you
become a very seminal artist that's
remembered it's because you had things
to say right and so with Michelangelo
was painting the Sistine Chapel and
inserted like symbolism into the work
that's going to stand the test of time
and things that have symbolic meaning
usually transcend right so if you create
shallow baby pool lukewarm nonsense that
may be visually stunning but you're just
doing it for some sort of you know
corporate crap yeah occasionally you can
insert something into that but I always
try to me I'm so in commercial that I
it's it's how do you balance being
commercial and sustaining revenue with
creating art right and a lot of artists
have to do very commercial things and
just like Michelangelo wanted to paint
his own thing but he had to paint what
the church wanted him to paint so it's
this struggle through all of time and
I've talked about it extensively up in
places I haven't ronnie has some
thoughts I understand your dilemma yes
for how do we stay afloat you know you
just have to cut back on your your needs
yes I remember living in my van I would
find a cheap spaces and warehouses that
would be just so ultra cheap you know I
remember in Biddeford Maine I found a
place I got myself on my own hot water
heater and a clawfoot bathtub and I was
good to go but again they are there's
also something among us too
that doesn't want us to create and make
these movies and write these songs and
poems and films and we have to be very
cautious especially now with creativity
with artificial intelligence you know we
have Neverland forces yeah that's a
desert it was good when Ron we're gonna
get there too
I want to let's let's hit on this point
quick just that what would Ron sing
about about like giving you know we give
up some of the some of the things along
this along the spiritual journey um one
of the things that has made it so much
different today is that now were like
were were you said like you used to be
burned by saying things that were
the point zero zero one percent now now
we actually have freedom more freedom of
speech with that which is fantastic at
the same time we have the the when you
take like a photo of the of yourself
when you're doing things like you're
worried about judgment so many people
are worried about judgment like if Ron
is to live in a van or a warehouse as he
does the artist of spiritual journey
like we're worried that our mom and our
friends and people like that people are
going to judge us yeah versus if we were
to just be like I don't care about that
and that stuff actually is there to just
hold me back from my path that would
help us a lot
yeah yet getting it through that yeah
it's like human beings aren't designed
to be in these massive judge dredd Magna
Tokyo cities you know Neo Tokyo cities
of lo big cities of lonely people you
know we're designed to be in Moorestown
community and so I think as we live more
authentically and we you could say that
we could have a whole another 17-hour
conversation recoil in the decline of
society but as society does slowly a
collapse of society isn't like this
zombie apocalypse thing it's just a slow
returning to more authentic ways of
being right and so you find more modest
and realistic ways of living and being
and you don't have such a high you know
cost of living and you look at other
cultures in the past like indigenous
cultures or Native American cultures
that lived in more communal aspects and
had you know the village raised the
child together and we have no cost of
living or the Amish go and build a barn
together and it's like it's done you
don't have to pay a mortgage for thirty
years these are ways that give you much
more freedom to be the artist or the
creative or you live in a tiny house
these days you know you do alternate
ways of being and acting that allow you
to feel your creative path which I have
always said that the creative path
through what we create is a
self-initiating ourselves into our own
growth processes and we always set these
challenges along the way
because life is hard and life is a
struggle and much of spirituality is
this is life it's the 3d it's not often
some other dimensional space even though
there's a reflection of that because
nothing comes from here everything comes
from elsewhere and that's kind of what
you could say a piece of wisdom is as
above so below
you know like if we have a higher
dimensional version of ourselves which
people call all sorts of different
things and it's fractal endowed to this
you know the inside is the cause and the
outsides of the effect or you could say
that for the above and below alright so
just finding ways to give yourself space
is key time and space and so you it's
difficult to do that when you're so your
wheels are spinning on a bunch of
[ __ ] oh sure yeah and so again I I'm
never gonna say that people should just
disavow their responsibilities you know
we all have to make money in commerce in
this current time space vector but how
do you it's always returns to these
stalks of ballots and I've found a way
we're luckily in my life I can balance
things that I can make a feature
documentary about things that would
never be allowed through the dark
sorcery gatekeepers
you know I'm not a big fan of
gatekeepers you know people that are
we've given ourselves a position of this
is what is good you know even things
like film festivals or laurels or these
things most film festivals aren't there
to help your film they're there to help
their festival occasionally you find
really cool people there but it's not
gonna it you know allowing content that
is so expansive through doesn't usually
go over well but on the other side of
that you you will hit hit an audience
where people are really inspired and see
it like you mentioned in the work where
they get it and that's really beautiful
and so you get occasional nice responses
from people that really like the work or
respect it and if I am in some sort of
conventional thing where people are
picking up on it and we happen to be in
some sort of festival and people get it
that's great too you know
I love I love the idea of a very deeply
spiritual spiritual awakening driven
film festival things like that that are
that are they're not for their own
personal growth of the film's game or
this festivals games right
I want to we need to know some some
questions here around the technicals of
these things so how what are you you
were giving us the you were writing out
the story and making the narration these
types of processes okay we get that yeah
but then there's the actual process of
going and identifying what equipment to
use where to go and film and how to edit
it all together doing things like in
situ
you have voiceovers with the beautiful
visuals happening yeah yeah
Sophia teaches about all that you learn
from experience and I have a background
making essentially pretty pictures for
big studio movies that were very high
budget and so I occasionally might still
find myself doing little freelance work
directing a commercial for a tech
company in the Bay Area or something and
so bringing that knowledge of production
value into a project I knew that I had
kind of synchronistically built up a
skill set where the four legs of my
cauldron my out chemical called renner
being able to write things direct things
shoot things and edit things and if you
can do those for you pretty unstoppable
as a filmmaker right yeah so I got to
the point where as I was ever so slowly'
transmuting myself from my older Dumber
self to what I am now and I certainly as
you have cycles of life where you become
the wise Gandalf wizard later in life or
in another life or many lives down the
line you can argue that people that are
understanding or trying to be on some
sort of path of betterment have been
here longer or older Souls you could say
also there's no more pillar the market I
wrote that one down right direct shoot
edit and mark it yes that's cute and
that's certainly a key component but
anyway like those technical aspects or
things that as I was becoming better at
doing those things I also sought out
people that were equally as
knowledgeable about the material if not
more so than me so Neil Cramer who wrote
this film is it way further on the path
than I was at the time and his so he was
the narrator and writer of the doc and
could speak to it in an excellent way so
I brought my production value to it well
he brought the wisdom to it and I just I
learned a lot just by being in this
proximity with him there's an ancient
term you'll like this it's called
disciplic succession and it's basically
like when you're next to somebody that's
wise it's like when when Luke went to go
visit Yoda in the Dagobah system Luke
gets disciplic succession from Yoda okay
I get the transmission of knowledge
session okay
I feel like Neal gave me disciplic
succession just by walking around the
Pacific Northwest and these ancient
old-growth forests with a real mystic
that actually transmitted information
and insight to me just like any you know
that you go up to the ashram on the
mountain to
kung fu in the kung fu master transmits
data and knowledge and wisdom to you and
so the same thing with every one of the
five people you surround yourself with
these types of yeah and that's why you
could you you oh it's it's important to
put yourself around people that are
knowledgeable as well or on your same
vibratory level same wavelength or
people that can teach you things and
that's what we grossly lack in our
societies wise elders of knowledge and
spirit you ever notice that there are
some people that surround themselves
with people that are not as smart as
there there's also phenomenon with men
and women that surround themselves with
people who are not as attractive as they
are more attractive oh that's funny man
when you talk about a new younger day
when you reference holiday that you
weren't very bright you or you who's
stupid I think I find that extremely
hard to believe I think even at your
worst
you are just shining above those beers
well thank you man I mean think I think
that we're all you know we have these as
kids we might be this little
introspective little kid you know who's
in our own world and like little kids
can see have read into things well like
you can be in some weird like you'd be
in some Southern Baptist Church but
you'd see this guy that's like Jesus
Christ he's talking in a fake voice and
the little kid in the little Baptist
Church instantly reads the fakeness of
the artificiality of this person right
so kids have pretty good discernment for
that usually until they're indoctrinated
apparently if they get you if something
indoctrinates you it's like like by age
7 or age 10 if they've got you it's
really hard to hold on indoctrinate
yourself to unplug from your matrix pod
so kids are pretty good about yeah
that's a great way to put it yeah yeah
but eggs into matrix plots as a little
introspective kid I did see things in
other ways and you don't have language
to describe what you're interested in or
why I like the dark psychedelia of the
band tool why am I called to you have a
you know on your coaster you have a cult
image of this hand right but you could
argue it's like the hamsa hand or they
hand of the mysteries as manually palmer
i would say but like why do will you
like a a hand that's in dark psychedelia
of the band tool why are you drawn to
that imagery but you don't know why so
it's like you you sir
you eventually get discerned enough that
you become to be able to describe these
things and communicate it to others and
that's what we can do well as we get
better and as we hopefully can share
knowledge and insight is how you
communicate it right yeah yeah yeah yeah
and that's the one of the major roles of
film poetry music comedy is to
disseminate these insights and awake and
inspire people yeah I love that okay
let's um and you said experience was the
big thing so actually going out and
learning these pillars um writing
directing shooting editing marketing and
going and doing that process over and
over again I I got so lucky that a
couple years ago that people started
telling me Alan just practice premiere
just go and start yeah I think your
learn by doing you learn by doing it so
quickly now we're making these cool
60-second videos mmm and it's really it
just takes the practice the experience
yeah yeah if you're gonna make something
on your own you might as well make it
paradigm crushing you know that it's not
gonna come it's not gonna come from the
top down it's gonna come from the bottom
up right so you make your paradigm I
can't put toothpaste into Oreos and feed
them to the homeless in that oh well
that metaphor is there there's no
putting the toothpaste back in the tube
when you've discovered something and you
want to somewhat insert that so that
that is the discouraging thing is there
such saturation of content now that a
lot of it is not very good you know it's
just like it might really win but what
does it have to say yeah and it's not
like my work is on this high horse but I
think that the works are starting to
give out a signal that they have things
to say and I'm happy with that right
from are the various forms of media I
create yeah yeah yeah okay so now let's
get the shamans of the global village
so the first episode when was that
published last year we made it we shot
it in 2015 and we made it in 2016 so
shamans at the global village I know you
talked about with rack but it's
basically an independent invested
investigative documentary series about
shamanic cultures in the shamanistic
path and how shamanism is a
component to a healthy civilization or
community because in our society these
days the metaphor I use is in all
respect to our loved ones is we have the
Society of essentially childish asleep
robots where we have these otamatone
people that are essentially little kids
and adult bodies right they haven't had
an initiatory experience into knowing
who they are how they fit into the
greater ecology of things so ancient
cultures always had these ceremonies or
these practices where you essentially go
on your spirit quest as you're a young
sprout in you know you're 16 and you go
on a spirit quest or you have a
psychedelic shamanic experience and you
you are it's you're initiated into
adulthood
right and just like these mindsets of
having our politicians that sadly every
once in a while surgeons law you get
people that are decent in politics but
you know you get these other deplorable
excuses for human beings that don't know
anything and they don't know anything
about like who they are what they're
doing or where we're going so having
this mindset where it's like what if we
initiated these people into shamanic
medicines as like just number one
precursor for being a representative
representative of the people and not
just special interests if you have a
larger understanding of what human
beings are and where we're going and why
we're doing these things and how we can
live in more authentic ways of being
that connect us more to Great Spirit you
know which is if you're interested in
nature or animal you know welfare or the
rights of indigenous people so it's like
all these things check the boxes of
being more connected more connected to
Great Spirit right Great Spirit just
being the larger ecology of things and
how animistic cultures have always
recognized they've used the term I've
talked to spirits you know that's just
their way of saying that my higher self
my higher vibrational density self which
sounds a little whoo but ultimately like
you your higher self that can connect to
knowledge and wisdom through what some
people call it Akashic record gives
gnosis or insight and you can get that
when you're tuned in enough when you
haven't had your not eating [ __ ] food or
you're not like drinking tons of you
know caffeine or you're masturbating
every day or you're doing these things
that are contractive even though there's
great times to have do all these things
you know to have all these there's
places for all things that can be
masturbating every day expanse
right it's great to have a have an
orgasmic experience like on occasion but
you know everything in moderation that
tune you into these larger you know the
greater ecology of things so that's just
what I'm saying is that if you again
back to balance always but we highlight
in the show ancient cultures that do
this very well and they have their own
problems too you know because they're
suffering through the the crisis times
of the environment these days with all
the crisis levels that we're at and the
struggles of them having to operate
within commerce and the current dynamic
so we highlight various tribal cultures
that have had a shamanic practice and
hopefully have given a lineage of
ancient wisdom through some what's
called neo shamanism you know modern-day
shamanism through somebody that might be
from the United States or might be from
Mexico or somebody that's from you know
an indigenous culture that is training
to become a shaman
that's essentially somebody that helps
people realize that so much of their
problems are a spiritual problem right
in terms of everything in terms of their
life issues in terms of health and
wellness and you know the petrochemical
pharmaceutical industry has such a
monopoly on health and and well-being
that they don't allowing any sort of
holistic things through or any sort of
things that aren't the status quo is
very difficult to get through so
shamanism becomes such a loaded term for
the again back to the unstring I mean
you know unreality signal of standard
operating procedure and as you could say
something very paradigm destroying which
is that all religion is based on Astro
theology our connection to the cosmos
and shamanism right because shamanism is
as old as the hills
I think shamanism is as old as however
many many long long time ago that we are
you know we see ancient civilizations
and cultures that clearly knew things
more than we did and I would say that's
because they had connection to Great
Spirit they were getting there
you know iCloud data downloads that were
giving them knowledge and insight as to
how to build this pyramid in this
specific point with this specific like
you know tools how would we did this in
advanced ways to connect up to the you
know that
the summer solstice at this particular
location of this particular time and you
see in ancient civilizations reflections
of this yeah where you wonder how much
like how did these people get this
insight and wisdom and it's because of
connection to our higher selves which is
that's the akan of kind of Empire is
just decoupling from who we really are
and what we're capable of right and get
all the powerfulness that we can
manifest and as we seek out our own pass
in life and I would say like you and I
talked about earlier finding our what
Joseph Campbell called like find your
bliss right like find your real way in
life that's really the reflection of you
so you do work or what Aleister Crowley
says is do what I will
she'll be the whole of the law find
things that allow you to fulfill your
true will and gives you energy so your
work gives you energy instead of taking
your energy your this you may be going
to we're here on Market Street in San
Francisco which is a wild and it's kind
of like the Cantina in Star Wars or
something is it time to see a whole
spectrum of the freaks of the industry
mixed with like you know they're very
professional tech people of going to
their jobs Joe it's ridiculous yeah and
you see the full spectrum of society and
how we have massive problems and yeah
amazing things that we're doing earth is
such a polarized place where you see
human beings are the giant biggest
scheming pieces of [ __ ] on earth and
they're also the most wonderful things
ever right and we have amazing
capabilities of bettering society I
think X just so eloquently described
your dichotomizing it so perfectly yeah
yeah it's it's kind of like kids you
know I have a two-year-old and it's the
same way the kids people always think
kids are so great and the truth is
they're both the biggest steaming pieces
of [ __ ] and the most wonderful things
that we've ever yeah exactly
next I'll show you that yeah and that's
yeah yeah anyway funny funny very very
well said
so much good stuff there now would would
we so so the first one was on the
Sonoran Desert toad and now in 2016 was
released that's correct
okay and there were some really profound
takeaways from that just just for me
just the way that humans connect to the
creatures of the Sonoran Desert on how
they connect to the land how they
connect to the to the to the spirit that
is work
with the creature to then get the the
venom that's secreted from the gland
yeah five Meo DMT yes I'm that that
whole thing it's not just a come here
let me get this from you I'm gone it's
it's a massive intent it's like a
connection divine and this next one
that's coming outs on the peyote cactus
episode that's correct yeah so episode
each episode focuses on a specific
medicine person working with a specific
medicine so the first episode was
released in 2016 completely
independently again we just made it
ourselves and you know as a slow drip
low-budget project we're just making
episodes hopefully more often than the
band tool makes an album pay-per-view
yeah like five dollars ten dollars yeah
we just pay for either you can download
it or rent it and in an ideal world
that's how you do it you create your
content there you is your own content
and you'd sell it directly to audience
so I really do love there's some nuance
because also there's like yes we want to
make our ability to continue making
content so people supporting us through
five or ten dollars of payments as well
as those that like can't afford it
around the world to even pay that much
to somehow have a look that's the dollar
ship version that's free so like this
content is free and then we just say hey
like you're getting a cup of coffee like
just give us five bucks a month to help
us do this there's different there's
different methods for this process it's
a good point when we go and visit a
tribe who has they do some beautiful
things and they also you see their
struggles and their hardships and how
many of those people could even afford
to rent the show right so as we just yes
just have filmed the second episode at
the time of this recording which is on
peyote and we just kind of let these
things come about synchronistically
again using the projects as our own beer
vehicles for growth and transmutation
and experience wrack and I just kind of
let them come about when they naturally
come and we get an offer to do something
or the stars aligned to make it happen
even with limited resources but it's a
good point that even us as independent
filmmakers you know just having a
monetization stream that can keep the
show going even though it's by no means
we're getting rich off this stuff but at
the same time it is allowing the gears
to turn ever so slowly to get to more
episodes
it's nice that you mentioned that from
reference points of like we're in the
Bay Area it's like you hear the
statistics about if you make $40,000
year that's nothing in the Bay Area but
for most of the world that's an amazing
amount of revenue so you it's very
intuitive struggle and not be the you
know imperialistic anthropologist but
more the journalist that sees how people
live and operate and how see so how see
how so much of the world has so little
materially and how they have their
struggles but how there's also things
that they do very well much of South
America you know they live in a dirt
floor huts but the kids are having a
great time yeah it's not like they don't
have their struggles but there's a
beauty to that rather than ROS hashtag
look up staring down at your stupid
smartphone yeah so balance balance again
you know I have a smartphone yeah so can
we oh this is good so can we can we
balance the the amount of signal that
we're getting from the get out rid of
the noise be vigilant don't go the joker
vortexes behind the signal I love George
Joker vortex that's such a girl from the
old Batman [ __ ] yeah like spirals coming
out of things yeah yes like you watch
the you know mainstream unreality signal
of bobblehead talking news networks
that's they're not a politics is not
about expanding language it's about
contracting language right so when you
get things that are contracting wants
it's about contracting yeah so when you
hear somebody that's talking about real
[ __ ] and it's like well they're actually
saying things that I haven't heard but
they're blowing my mind you know like
like right now like you know philip k
dick wrote or something you're like wow
he's actually saying things that are
expansive that is it should be a beacon
for following that signal right ah okay
got it guys so that acts as a beacon -
okay cool so okay so beacon is expansive
thinking okay I would hope so I like
that I like that and versus contracting
which is a lot of what the the
mainstream political narratives is right
because it's like do you ever see the
metaphor I use for that is in the 60s
you know revolution did you see Richard
Nixon saying really amazing empowering
things or did you see Timothy Leary
saying amazing empowering things and who
is the most dangerous man in America
Yeah right so there's the I sometimes
use this term Mirror Mirror where it's
like everything is mirrored back to
front right so what you thought was the
case oftentimes turns out to be the
exact opposite right and that's you see
that even more in other countries where
you see that things are usually back to
front and upside down and so as you
start following a path of wisdom or what
you could say is a cult ism just means
hidden so people think it means all this
dark [ __ ] of like standing around doing
a bloody pentagram you know doing some
crazy ritual and there are there is dark
occultism out there and you know things
with high level pedophilia and the
entertainment industry and things like
that but much of a cult practice is just
about empowering yourself through your
own practices to do things that you know
give us o Taric insight so that comment
that I just laid down I think is a
reflection of having esoteric
development through our experiences that
give us real gnosis that then you can
see what is actually the nature
ever-so-slightly of reality right like
what is real versus what is not and
you'd be surprised how much of reality
is illusory right now and so a lot of
the times in Chavez at the global
village you know we'll get some the
shaman will tell us something about how
the earth changes now or a reflection of
how human beings are acting there's
really act like dumbasses the guy in
ecosystem the larger ecology will force
us to do things that stop us from doing
unsustainable practices things like that
so there's a huge as above so below
connection with how we do things and are
the larger greater ecology of things and
I think human beings are extremely
powerful and we're tricked into thinking
that we don't have any power right so
Commerce is a huge tool that uses that
that just distracts us into the realm of
wasting our time or spinning our wheels
and as everything is corporatized you
see much less wisdom in that you know
our names are corporatized are yeah you
know you know what I mean yeah yeah it
may be a good couple words for this our
origins are op you skated sure yeah sure
as soon as that obfuscation happens
distractions distortions Joker vortexes
the the nature the connection to nature
to spirit to source where we all came
from how we all breathe the air and how
we're all interconnected with all that
is here on the planet
that the gratitude that we have for even
the water and the food and the showers
on this it's out the window because the
obfuscation is there taking us away from
the origins yeah and that's just
distraction I mean so much of life is
distraction from what is a good way of
being right how you can truly spend your
time and I think that we come here to
learn and to grow and if we spend our
time doing things that are excellent and
fulfilling then it's much more rewarding
and you feel better you know you have
much less suffering in your life and
it's just like it's like the dynamic
where some experience that is a if you
have you know years of meditating how
much better you feel you know maybe
that's not for everybody or if you have
an able gain experience you know a boga
can be ten years of psychotherapy and
two nights so there's all sorts of
beautiful ways to get to it or you have
you know another metaphor metaphor for a
spiritual path is like mountaineering or
something you know some pilgrimage use
go on through you know a Himalayan trip
or something you know that's not a good
example because people do so much damage
to Mount Everest as they climb it I just
read an article they live thousands of
piles of junk on it but like that's the
reason why the Himalayans shook off some
of the tibetan from them obviously was
because they didn't ask the mountains if
they could set up o a Civ they didn't
they didn't connect to the greater
ecology and asked the mountain if it was
the right time to do it or they didn't
have knowledge of their solar lunar
cycles the astrological perspectives of
like is this the proper time to do this
you know just like ancient cultures did
they knew when was the proper time to
plant or sea or when was the proper time
to set up this monument it's like that
connection gives us much more wisdom for
a real way of being and in this room -
we have to tell ourselves that who where
we're at in this room who was initially
on this land a thousand or more years
ago that was on this land first yes and
do you have another way of looking at
that is do you know not to say people to
just do an ancestry test but do you know
your lineage of your where you're from
and where your people are from and have
you visited your land yeah that type of
stuff has huge benefit but the point of
what I was gonna say is just the
pilgrimage right it's the pilgrimage
when we make these shows it's always
like a pilgrimage for us
it's very difficult and a huge amount of
struggling the rack may have talked
about that but it's very rewarding and
each time it's like we level up in
Donkey Kong every time every show is a
level so it's experience points yeah you
guys it's a it's a leveling up because
you do with so much more rarer yes it's
there slow drip projects and yes these
projects I this is documentary
narrations yeah I've just gotten in the
habit of like taking all this I shoot
thousands of hours of this footage we're
hopefully beautiful stuff and it's like
how can I just use some of this footage
as extra little snippets of insight that
are smaller drip projects so I just post
them as like these little tone poem
e-s-a things we were talking about you
know your writing and how you'll write
something put it over an intro piece and
that's essentially like you making a
mini Doc I find myself occasionally I
will also call myself an essayist even
though I'm amateur at that but essays
are way to insert some sort of insight
into things just sharing life insights
and so as somebody that creates essays
as well spoken word essays I've also
started as a documentary filmmaker just
writing documentaries that are
essentially just like a visual essay so
these documentary narrations are just me
writing out hopefully something that's
just a piece of insight over something
that has relevant visual yumminess and
putting those two together right and so
I'll just drop those as little bread
crumbs along their way yes and you know
it's just fun just you enjoy doing it
gives you energy it doesn't take your
energy it's not about you know we could
talk about the balance of how great it
is to have see people see your stuff
amongst being so commercial in your you
know promotion of stuff but I also
understand that marketability and
commercialism has its place in today's
society so again as any artist I'm no
different I would love people to know
the work and recognize the work and
appreciate the work but we we also see
an mirror mirror that some of the most
rubbish content is the most popular
content you know we don't get we all
know that the little the most best music
doesn't come from top 40 it comes from
the little indie Garage Band or
something like that or we know that
people's you know that sometimes the top
100 people are the worst 100 people you
know these influencers of you know slimy
things that just project stuff that
doesn't have any it's all about material
game it's all about material
essentially which you know usually gets
the most eyes eyeballs on stuff because
of its commercial value and one secret
to real excellence is that it is never
commercial right yeah yeah and you you
again balance so sometimes you'll have
something that leads you into something
but if you find the real yummy stuff the
real wisdom it's not going to be very
it'll be little it'll have little
commercial allottee if none yes yes yeah
and that's kind of the ancient wisdom
the mystery school dynamic of like how
do you seek out real people doing
excellent things and underground ways is
there not gonna be broadcasting signal
to the public there going to be kind of
on them I don't wanna say they're on the
shady dark web or something but they're
you find them through word-of-mouth or
you find them in old paradigm ways of
who did that you know amazing blacksmith
work for you in the old village you're
you hear about it through that's who the
network's yeah right and that's how you
find people that are really I think are
influential to you on your on your life
in your life the there's like even even
with the even with the show like this or
with your viewership is that actually
our content is 99% that are people that
are watching the content otherwise
there'd be no purpose for it sure
so like it's like thank you for watching
yeah and it's night it's lovely to have
feedback on your work and have people
appreciate your work and as you know
somebody that is doing their own thing
that's always some of my biggest life
problems at this time space vector are
issues of scale right it's like you do
you find a balance in your life or
you're at that frequency where
everything you're doing is great and you
really are happy and you're resonating
but then how do you make it work scale
wise and you don't want to be so scaled
up that it becomes you know elements of
dark sorcery that become contractive and
I think that when somebody starts some
company and it they have good intentions
original and then it becomes this
malevolent thing this Hydra this
tentacle Hydra that's invading all
aspects of our lives through NSA spying
and dogs dark skullduggery it's like did
the founder of that small entity really
planned for that to happen I think it
gets co-opted at at some point but at
the same time as we are small
enterprises or maybe small business
owners it's great to support your small
business and yeah let them know that you
appreciate the work like any author you
know like
anybody that writes a book or paints a
painting it's like yeah we love your art
we love your work yes yes yes yes you
watch a good video comment thank you
yeah you know just the simple things
matter so much we send a quick email
thank you that was very profound you've
inspired me or what have you or if
there's feedback you can potentially do
this or that better we appreciate
proactive proactive feedback like not
being a reactionary you know whiney
person you you also said that there's a
ton of signal potentially in the shows
that have like the least amount of views
and stuff I thought there's also poop
there too oh sure yeah it's interesting
there's there's legal dichotomy between
having there being within the Perret oh
so much crap at the tail end but also
that's a good one too yeah grab fecal
legal crap that there's so much of that
but then there's also really good
nuggets some of the most profound videos
I've seen on the internet have like 20
views or ha use so these are other
things let's let's hit on this point
quick and I'm actually interested to
hear how Ron ends up playing with you on
this point but tell us about the dark
gatekeepers yeah I mean it's hard to say
you can only really talk about what you
know experientially and you can hear
stories from like secondhand type
dynamics I know somebody when I was
working in Hollywood that said that this
was not me experiencing this directly
because I wasn't at a higher not high
enough level in the hierarchy to be
invited to this thing but he said that
he was essentially invited to a real
Kubrick ian's Eyes Wide Shut sex orgy at
some you know mansion in LA and there
were very knowledgeable people there so
that type of stuff you know does go on
it resonates what you can really only
speak to is what alright so no surprise
that as we literally started talking
about the dark gatekeepers that the
stream crashed and so now we'll just be
stitching together this recording with
the first one so Wow Ron's been talking
about this stuff for a long time and
it's finally starting to creep up more
and more into my awareness and wow it
just happened to us and you have been
talking about these dark days
keepers to me since we've started
talking as well so why don't you now
start teaching us about what this really
is again I'm not an expert on it I'm
just a student of all this and I could
you can only speak to what you've
experienced and what also you feel into
right so dark gatekeepers is just my
magical language to describe things that
aren't in your best interest or do not
provide you with expansion they provide
you with contraction and we find as we
go along a path of self betterment or
being what you might cone I ought o
Didact
a self-taught person you find it's like
why didn't I know about this why is the
schooling system intentionally dumbing
me down or why is the health you know
why are why am I getting all this poor
information on what is accurate for what
I should be putting in my body and then
you come to realize that you know these
industries that are essentially supposed
to be helping us and they call it they
reduce us into these things called
consumers which sounds like something
that would be on a Black Friday zombie
apocalypse you know video as us are not
consumers we're actually infinite
fractals of consciousness and you know
we're beings that have huge powerful
capability we come to realize that these
there's sources at foot that are
intentionally trying to restrict us and
contract us and the only way to again
move beyond these things is how what we
do on our own and what we self discover
through our own paths of betterment and
discovery and I would argue that that is
an initiative process for every person
in their life you are here in life to
initiate yourself through a series of
obstacles in life that the you could
call Empire or what Phillip Phillip K
dick called it Empire just systems that
distract and provide illusion through
every channel right make it's very
conspiratorial you know it gets through
you could you could go down endless
conspiratorial paths and one step along
the journey of betterment or discovery
or spiritual growth is you know kind of
breaking through the glass ceilings of
of conspiracy and not getting so bogged
down in only conspiracy and like FEMA
trailers and chemtrails and all this
stuff but realizing that again
polarization of life there's
horrendously awful things going on and
there's also striking amazing beauty
going on so how do you look at all these
things from a glass half ball glass half
full perspective excuse me
of being a creditor and not a debtor or
not somebody that's in service to others
instead of just service to self and
turning to the dark side essentially of
like going down what's called in magic
you know a sorcery path versus a wizard
path which is that's more you know
fiction but as you could separate the
Lord of the Rings versus some sort of
legitimate ceremonial magical practice
that somebody has in real life but it
feels to me and everything that I've
learned through my break throughs that
I've realized these things are there and
they didn't tell me that
and it's like why didn't you tell me
that you know why did I have to learn
that on my own or why did I have to hear
about that word of mouth so system wise
as things get centralized and big
they're more prevalent in constricting
human consciousness and contracting
human beings right and so the sovereign
awake human is there to grow and break
through these things and it's every node
of the network you know slowly improves
its kind of end game for old ways of
operating and that's why we see that we
need to move on to new societal ways of
operating systems and even people that
might listen to this or in their
standard operating procedure know that
they're in a system that's rubbish but
people have huge excellence right so
it's like systems become rubbish and
then we as individual nodes need to do
our own need to broadcast beacons to be
our own excellent selves and how can we
slowly get rid of old systems and I
don't think it's a massive crash but
it's like how does you know something
like a new technology like crypto
currencies over 30 years become the new
currency from you know a horrendously
dark sorcery centralized fiat money
systems that have you know run by then
what is it in John Carpenter's they live
those aliens with like the rubber masks
oh no or you know you can even get into
very high metaphysical conversations
about you know entities that are non
corporeal things that are controlling
human beings or control it's like a
control Factory I don't get into that
we're in this hive of restriction in our
matrix pods and it's almond Evelyn I
think that we are in a realm that's a
beautiful place yes so we act like as we
become more conscious we realize that
we're in this we have this capability to
make this reality a garden and that's
what yes we should be we're not here to
exploit and
pollute and do awful things that are
again sometimes sustainable becomes a
little bit of a buzzword but one of the
thoughts is that if the if this body if
we ourselves are not consciously
connected to source of spirit in our own
North Star and following that trajectory
of waiting Joker vortexes yes gives the
space for the evil entity to occupy and
then the run/walk astound jewel core
vortexes and all the nonsense yes yes my
colleague on transportation neil kramer
does an excellent job of talking about
empire from an esoteric perspective I
originally found a modern version of
empire through philip k dick and his
Brooke book valise he continuously
references the fact that the Empire
never ended and it just goes kind of
it's just either on the surface or else
it goes kind of underground right no
it's either what is it when it's either
out in the open or else it's hidden yeah
so it's it's that's that's what's going
on is we have we live in modern times
which it's a beautiful time to be alive
but there's very much still systems that
don't benefit us and how can we find
ways of doing our true will or following
our bliss that operate in new ways of
being or like systems that are communal
sharing systems and again I think we get
back to all original ways of living in
more in community and then maybe we'll
have a society that's more connected to
spirit and we have you know excellent
wise elders or excellent shamans and the
distractions and illusions go away you
know they are they the signal-to-noise
ratio of the negative is reduced because
people don't they don't it doesn't work
on them anymore you know even something
like commercial content it's like can
you listen to can you watch standard
television ads and does that work on you
no not at all not at all and and I've
even went as far as to plug my ears when
listening to the top radio album rising
in the car the / it's like no I refuse
to listen to it cuz you're at a you're
at a level where your sounds wooly but
you're vibrating higher than that stuff
I don't want to hear the money drugs
women materialistic possessions music I
don't want to hear it I it's actually it
it if you don't think it makes an impact
on you moment to moment to moment it
totally does so you can cancel out your
neural infrastructure having to deal
with listening to that even that
actually upgrades you further and same
thing with the commercials you're like
do they work on no they said no can you
you're giving us all of this on the dark
gatekeeper stuff from the abstract which
I totally in big picture stuff you're
just super important but give us the
exact examples of your the way that
you've been like publishing content and
how those these forces have impacted you
well I mean I think my work personally I
always find that it's it's hard to reach
anything that bypasses a gatekeeper so
my work is constantly shut down by the
gatekeepers and called the gatekeepers
anything I mean you can call the
gatekeepers like I mentioned a Film
Festival or somebody that promotes
content you know Rises content up to a
higher place and we could get very deep
in the weeds of how commercial and
marketable it is but a lot of it is just
you know designed to not just speak to
the Burning Man crowd or the inner crowd
of what you know the psychedelic
community is or people that are
interested in spiritual growth or a cult
or esoteric content which is few because
again back to the original origins of
this conversation most people don't even
know what those things are what they
mean but as they find that these are
core excellences that empower human
beings and the secrets to reality will
be found through the gates of these
things right through some of these
practices that we mentioned that's very
empowering to people and to people that
are interested that have the ears to
hear it so I always try and put forth
stuff that even though it's such
hopefully decent content I'm shocked by
how much it's shut down right now
that doesn't mean that it's shut down by
people that would connect with it when
people see it it's like oh I loved it
that's great and that you know
occasionally I will get great responses
like that like hopefully you find you do
through the show as well but I always
find that the most it's not just
directly or easier fair to say that the
most rubbish stuff is the most seen
stuff because sometimes you see stuff
that's very you know gets a broad reach
and it's pretty good that's great I call
it being on the high traffic highways
versus being off in the wilderness
somewhere right so as you make things
that the more you know the less people
understand what you're talking about so
you have to find
dynamic of how do I insert something in
here that's translatable and relatable
versus how do I make something that's so
esoteric weird they're not even gonna
get it then you're often you know again
the forest from the trees and then the
ultimate way is the more you know and
the better you can communicate yes yeah
that's the real gem of a person another
example and I haven't had a direct
experience that with this is something
like this would be super super a
paradigm destroying but you start
getting into things where you advocate
certain holistic practices for health
and you know somebody that's had has
cancer or something and they're you know
being told that traditional ways of
treating cancer when there's all these
suppressed ways of treating cancer
through herbal remedies or through you
know shark
what is it sharks don't get cancer or
like you know there's cannabis is a you
know a suppressed cure for cancer and
there's various forms of there's a se
acti that apparently is a you know
remedy there's there's these you can lit
you can find about 10 legit or at least
seeming to feel like they have some
validity you know alternate cancer
treatments for me and I haven't had the
personal experience of having cancer and
see them work on me personally but
they're what they're doing resonates
with me and then you see the massive you
know healthcare industry which is as you
know top-down as you get as the fossil
fuel industry or the pharmaceutical
industry is you know that's a place that
cares more about its profits than the
health and well-being of its patients
I'm not saying it doesn't care about the
health and well-being of patients it's
just a very distant second to its
massive corporate profits so when
massive corporate profits get in the way
and this is not a left or right thing
because it's corporatized government
yeah it should be completely not
political it's not political so perverse
incentives yeah so I have had things
that I've done holistically are
beneficially that I was never told that
by a doctor I was never told that by
somebody that's a sanctioned authority
on the thing from you know there being
having a PhD or being a college
professor or being a lawyer it's like
there's a lot of things that you can
find within the legal industry with in
what's called sovereignty of your own
legal entity that you're never told
about like a standard lawyer or you
never are told about the Trivium
education
system that we used to know about that
you know in the 1800s there's like
letter beautifully articulate written
letters of deep you know verbal
sophistication written by war soldiers
in the 1800s because they had a
traditional liberal arts education and
it's like how come schoolteachers today
don't know about the seven liberal arts
you know of grammar logic rhetoric and
go down the line of that so there's all
this stuff that is essentially kept from
us that's suppressed that is now coming
the Internet has been a great tool to
reveal these things even though there's
always top-down forces trying to turn
off insightful stuff and it doesn't mean
that you know we shouldn't suppress
things that are you know hateful things
but at the same time as hate speech free
speech so it gets into a big topic of
conversation of like is it very healthy
to recognize alternate spatial models of
the universe versus you know recognizing
and admitting to everything that a
massive scientific organization would
tell us so it's it's a whole you know it
has to it goes into every aspect of your
life this stuff and it's it very much
changes you or you could say transmutes
you as you you know continue doing it in
your life will have to revisit another
conversation with Niles about about all
this stuff and what we could bring rack
back and Ryan in different emboss and
stuff and different vile yeah
it would be it would be another good
conversation for sure wolf to do that
maybe later this summer okay let's wrap
on a couple um let's that were a trap on
a couple questions yeah so you've
already
I think mentioned this throughout the
show a couple times but well what what
is the the grand narrative from all that
is into these human earth suits
that's a 50,000 hour conversation I
would just say that
ask a question like that let's just ask
to see I have a very simple answer that
drugs to do that's their very simple
answer is that we are we are spiritual
beings having a human experience
spiritual beings having a human
experience absolutely I've found it to
absolutely be the case and it doesn't
mean that you are in some sort of
traditional structure of Orthodoxy
but esotericism has helped my life
hugely by empowering me and giving me
less suffering right and so I would
HIGHLY encourage seek out people that
have esoteric knowledge and insight
somebody like Rudolf Steiner for example
or George or voinovich Georgie for
Helena Blavatsky or you know you can go
down the list of various people that
have stuff that when you read you don't
understand it's like reading the towel
to chain or it's like I don't understand
any of this but keep revisiting it you
know keep seeking out good content
because what you input will outwardly
manifest in what you output so input
yummy information so you can output
yummy information that's right and you
know create more and consume less that's
right I love it spiritual beings having
human experiences create more consume
less yeah all right let's hit on the
next question are we alone in the cosmos
I don't think so you know again another
15 hour conversation when you look at
the cosmos of like what's off earth is
material I have this bonkers psychedelic
experience once where I always glean
some insight that felt that like
everything offworld is other dimensional
right so the inner verse is very cosmic
and all some of my psychedelic
experiences have been very astral cosmic
and what you could argue there's an
ancient book of hermetic philosophy
called the corpus Hermeticum that isn't
saying the earth is flat or anything
like that but it's giving you some
insights as to like alternate spatial
models of the universe and what we are
in is different than what we think nor
does it mean it's like a snow globe with
puppet string holders out of it that are
you know robots you know controlling us
and summon evelyn cage but what we're in
we don't quite understand and so I had
this excited this feeling that
everything in the outer verse is really
the inner verse vice versa right so
whatever we're we're saying that we're
alone in the universe so that we can go
offworld in a gazillion ton
you know beryllium starship like McKenna
used to say is that really the way we do
it do we just do it by consuming a plant
and going to meet our ancestors or see
another civilization that absolutely
resonates that you do it through the
inner verse you don't do it through the
outer verse and this is potentially one
of the reasons for the Fermi paradox is
that civilizations go inward rather than
beautifully so yeah you said it yeah and
you could also say that those things
technically are the same thing which is
like you can really spend your wheels in
yeah it's hard to it takes time to
communicate things simply and
effectively that are very difficult
concepts and this is why we have to
break away from civilization into an
inward and spend lots of time alone to
do these things turning inward that's
another good just meme yeah tune in and
we're doing inward yeah and then are we
in a simulation interesting question I
would say if we are it's not mine Evelyn
it's just something that's a growth it's
a growth lab it's like a lab for souls
to grow Souls train souls transit here
to grow right and then you go elsewhere
it to be like what did you learn and
then how much did you discover and you
get to a certain state where you evolve
to a higher higher density right so
there's higher density beings that were
once down here in this evolutionary
place overall but there is a malevolent
yeah there's components to the
simulation don't you know for the kids
right I wouldn't put it in the
monovalent box but I say again there are
level of things there are a benevolent
forces at play and part of your growth
is working beyond those yeah and that's
really tough because it's like well how
is that nice how does that apply to my
life now with my problems I'm having I'm
struggling with X Y Z I haven't talked
to my sister and you know three years I
struggled to pay rent these very
material concretize problems again
structure a life so you have more time
to to look into things of excellence and
not spend it with people that are energy
vampires vampires you know yeah yeah
that's it yeah okay and the last
question is what is the most beautiful
thing in the world
conversations like this buddy you know a
space where you can have a real
conversation is beautiful
I would say that when you wrap it up as
well and you have people that you know
our fond of you and remembered you and
you had some ever-so-slight influence on
bettering others right service to others
and not just service to self you can
only help yourself you can't help others
unless you help yourself though so it's
like help yourself get yourself good and
straight and right and then you can
hopefully do yours ever-so-slight pardon
benefiting others so that's there's a
beauty when you wrap it up whenever you
whatever your time is and you've
hopefully had benefit to others and
there's a there's a wide I'll tell you
one last thing in the corpus Hermeticum
which is a book of hermetic philosophy
there's a there's a thing in it that
says don't die without any children and
it doesn't mean physical children's it
coated because again we were
communicated to by synchronicity and
symbolism in the day and our dreams at
night we could have a whole nother to
conversation about dreams but children
are those who we help along our journey
that's Christ so don't die without
helping a Carsley know them on their
journey it's not just like how you give
them material success how you help them
in their journey right so yeah that's a
piece of beauty oh yeah I don't think
I've ever taken this many notes from a
conversation alright this has been super
profound not really enlightening I feel
like just on a whole nother level
thank you you should feel better after a
conversation and if you feel like you've
had a interview that's gone rubbish or
it's weird or again it's taken energy
and your second I'm not sure about that
you should feel like pumped after the
conversation so I hope that all is gone
yeah yeah you crushed it oh thank you
such a pleasure
such a pleasure the network yeah and
when the mesh network ahh Wow but yeah
the fact right though will you teach us
about the dark gatekeepers dream cuts
yeah it was crazy that that happened
yeah so huge thank you everyone for
tuning in we greatly appreciate it make
sure to go in tune in word now as well
go and check out the links in the bio
below to Niles's work check out nyle
segments calm transmutation of film
common soil shamans global village calm
support artists and entrepreneurs like
Niles here go in to rent the
than with your friends get talking more
about ancient wisdom in modern times go
and do that everyone let's get let's get
going towards the what we talked about
in the conversation today and support
simulation are linked so are below help
us grow and prosper as well huge shout
out to Ron Vargas for producing and
directing thank you very much Ronnie and
run yes and go and build the future
everyone manifests your dreams into the
world thank you for tuning in and we
will see you soon peace
[Music]
[Music]
you